we still got his great room first
Keystone of the forge I don't know what
that is in a shimmering Relic Remnant
Remnant crafting okay I think this is
where we make a Talisman chat we should
do this chime of Godwin that is so cool
increases our lightning damage oh
balls my man
come on balls
I actually like that better than the dog
fighting here look at her hair
whoa I dig this look a lot this looks
really cool I I like this look more than
her pointy hat look this is actually a
way better Grace location you don't have
to run all the way back which is the
most annoying run in Elden Rank and then
you get to look inside the library from
here and like see her cradling the egg
this is a great addition